la compañía ha ofrece 10.000 el primer
mes se irá incrementando la cantidad en
cinco mil cada mes la compañía ve ofrece
500 el primer mes el irá duplicando esta
cantidad cada mes en cual mes el pago de
la compañía ve será mayor por primera
vez al pago de la compañía a pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta
resolvamos esto juntos hagamos una tabla
la primera columna será del mes la
segunda columna es lo que pagará la
compañía
y la tercera columna es lo que pagará la
compañía ve nos dicen que en el primer
mes la compañía
va a pagar 10 mil la compañía ve ofrece
500 el primer mes
y después nos dicen que esta compañía
irá incrementando la cantidad en 5000
cada mes en el segundo mes aquí
tendremos 5 mil más que son 15.000 en el
tercer mes tendremos 20 mil en el cuarto
mes tendremos 25 mil en el quinto mes
tendremos 30 mil y creo que ya se están
dando cuenta hacia dónde vamos en el
sexto mes tendremos 35 mil en el séptimo
mes 40 mil y en el octavo mes tendremos
45 mil ahora veamos qué va a pasar con
la compañía de la compañía ve ofrece 500
el primer mes e irá duplicando esta
cantidad cada mes así que en el segundo
mes vamos a duplicar esto y tendremos
1000 para el tercer mes vamos a duplicar
esto lo que nos dará 2000 luego lo
duplicamos de nuevo 4000 lo duplicamos
nuevamente 8000 duplicamos de nuevo
16.000
nuevamente lo duplicamos nos da 32.000 y
de nuevo lo duplicamos en el octavo mes
nos da 64 mil y aquí algo interesante
ocurre ya que en el octavo mes el pago
de la compañía ve es mayor que el pago
de la compañía
así que ya podemos responder a la
pregunta en cual mes el pago de la
compañía ve será mayor por primera vez
al pago de la compañía pues en el octavo
mes mes 8 y aquí tenemos una elección
interesante pueden darse cuenta que la
tasa a la cual la compañía
va aumentando su pago es lineal cada mes
se incrementa en la misma cantidad más
5000 más 5000 y así sucesivamente
en cambio la compañía ve incrementa su
pago exponencialmente y se incrementa
con el mismo factor cada mes lo
multiplicamos por 2 y luego nuevamente
lo multiplicamos por 2 y así
sucesivamente por lo que aquí hay algo
muy interesante que algo que se está
incrementando exponencialmente
superará eventualmente a algo que se
está incrementando linealmente sin
importar cuál sea la situación inicial y
tampoco importa cuál sea la tasa del
incremento exponencial
eventualmente superará al incremento
lineal pueden ver esto visualmente si yo
dibujara una gráfica aquí si yo dibujara
aquí una función lineal y dibujo mi
función lineal que obviamente va a ser
una línea y una función exponencial
aunque comience un poco más abajo
eventualmente superará a la función
lineal y esto sucede aunque la función
lineal tenga una pendiente muy elevada o
un punto inicial muy elevado aún cuando
la función exponencial comience muy por
debajo y su crecimiento sea
relativamente pequeño eventualmente va a
superar a la función lineal lo que es
bastante interesante